as you mentioned at the top of the
program right now metro police are
investigating the discovery of a baby
in a trash bag that baby is alive
a bright spot on an otherwise dark story
but this afternoon metro police are
looking for the baby's mother
this discovery was made over the weekend
near jones and lake mead
bianca holman live right now from the
apartment complex where the baby was
found with the latest from metro bianca
good afternoon
afternoon that newborn was found sunday
afternoon by a family who heard the
infant
crying metro is now searching for the
child's mother
now it was sunday afternoon when the
family heard cries coming from the
bushes outside their window sunday
afternoon
the children in the family went outside
and found a one-day-old african-american
baby girl inside a trash bag
with the umbilical cord still attached
they took the baby upstairs to their mom
who called 9-1-1
the child was taken to umc hospital for
treatment
we have a law in this state to prevent
this
and that is the safe haven law anyone
in this situation can drop off a baby
under 30 days old at any fire station
medical facility ambulance no questions
asked
walk away the law prevents that anybody
follows them prevents from asking
further questions
and there's no repercussions the only
concern is the concern of that child
metro says the baby had minor scrapes
and bruises but it was a full
term infant once the infant is okay to
leave the hospital she'll be in the care
of child protective services
and placed with a foster family metro
says the complex did not have any
cameras in the area but they are
investigating surrounding businesses
for surveillance footage detectives are
asking the public's help to help
identify and locate the mother who they
suspect may live in the nearby area and
also there is no word yet on if she
would face any charges but right now
they just want to locate her
to offer her any medical help reporting
from near
jones and lake mead bianca holman 8 news
now